i think just generally the the path to
leadership should not be
uh through um you know basically
nba business school situation it's it's
like it should be
kind of work your way up do useful
things well i think
introverts can do quite well there's
this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from elon musk
bill gates and other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one earn it
with elon musk i think just generally
the the path to leadership should
not be through um
you know basically nba business school
situation it's
it's like it should be kind of work your
way up do useful things
and um you know and there's a bit too
much of the
somebody goes to a high-profile mba
school and then kind of parachutes in
as the as the leader but they don't
actually know how things work
um they you know they could be good at
say powerpoint presentations or
something like that
and they can present well but they don't
actually know how things work
because they do not um you know they're
they're they're they don't they like
parachute instead of like working their
way out yeah yeah
they never went through an
apprenticeship from yeah yeah
yeah they're so they're they're kind of
like just not aware of
what's really needed for uh you know to
make to make great products
um so i mean i don't want to trash
mbas too much here and i actually do
have a dual undergrad
wharton undergrad and physics at upenn
so
um you know so i have like you know it's
i have direct exposure to
to uh um you know to business school and
i
went you know to do undergrad physical
with with physics
but um and i was a teaching assistant
for two
semesters and i graded mbas and uh
undergrads
um so uh but i think it's just a little
bit too much
like like if people look at mba school
as like
i want to parachute into being the boss
instead of earning it
and like i don't think that's that's
good lesson number two
tap into different skills with bill
gates well i think
introverts can do quite well
i think there's you know if you're
clever you can learn to get the benefits
of being an introvert which might be say
being willing to go off for a few days
and think about a tough problem
read everything you can push yourself
very hard to think out on the edge
of that area and then if you
come up with something if you want to
hire people get them excited
build a company around that idea you
better learn what extroverts do you
better hire some extroverts
like steve ballmer i would claim as an
extrovert uh
and tap into both sets of skills in
order to have a company that
uh that thrives both as in deep thinking
and
building teams and and going out into
the world to sell those ideas
lesson number three delegate with jeff
bezos
i tell senior executives you should have
the least
stress you know there's this weird i
think false
uh idea that ceos
i'm a ceo there's this false idea
that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and uh so it's you have to figure out
how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
lesson number four pay attention to your
money with grant cardone
what would be um a few non-negotiables
that everyone should take with their
money like if okay if you don't if
you've got a hundred
thousand you want to get to a million
you've got a million went to 10. pay
attention to it
okay pay attention you should look at
your money every day look at it every
day look at the bank account look at the
bank account how many
what are your cash accounts and what are
your investments look at it every day
every single day it takes what is that
five seconds what does that do for you
where am i
inventory personal inventory mm-hmm
so where am i it's measurable you can
see it
if it's zero look at it until it makes
you sick
okay and then you see some money sitting
in a bank okay you got 100 grand sitting
in a bank account or 50 grand
okay you need look look what's what is
it earning
people are unconscious they don't know
where their money is
this is the scam on on on this planet
you give money you work your ass off and
then you give it to an institution
and you forget that it's there wells
fargo is paying you nothing bank of
america
is paying you nothing you send it to
chase they're not paying you anything
you send it to to the mutual fund you
don't even know what it's invested in
it's invested in stuff you don't even
believe in right it's invested in war
stocks
tobacco stocks drug companies
like you that's not things you even
believe in like like people have their
money
like that's that's not even
conducive with the things they believe
in in their life yeah
so um you know if you don't drink
alcohol why would you invest your money
in alcohol stocks true
so so pay attention to where the money
is what is it paying you
where is it look at it every day it
takes literally two minutes or less
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easy spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five be great at
selling with mark cuban you come up with
an idea where you say i can make dollar
bills for 50 cents
would you go out and raise money or
would you just go out and sell it
you just go out and do it you know and
and that's what you have to do and look
we all go through that fear factor of do
i quit my job
do i can i do this um can i
can i do this and what happens next the
one thing
i i know with 100 certainty and what i
would tell myself is
if i can sell and become a better and
better sales person
and be great at selling i'm always going
to be successful
whether i'm working for myself or if the
company that i started just didn't work
i'll give you an example out of indiana
before i went down to dallas i needed to
start something
and um i decided that everybody drank
milk
and i found this product powdered milk
that was cheaper
and everybody needed to save money and i
was going to go out there
and sell it um because it was cheaper
now it didn't taste quite as good
and so what i've but i went out there to
try to sell it
failed miserably but i learned
how to make the sales effort even when
things weren't going right
i learned that the rejection was
every no got me closer to a yes that not
every product was perfect
but i could take those same skills even
in failure
and translate them so that what i
learned selling garbage bags
door-to-door what i learned from selling
powdered milk that was awful what i
learned from
selling local area networks at micro
solutions
all those things accumulated and i i got
better at selling so i always knew
you know people always say to me if you
lost everything what would you do
i can sell i can sell and it's not about
selling ice to eskimos it's not about
you know convincing people to do this
selling is
always about helping selling is always
about
understanding the person you're talking
to and what their needs are
and if someone can help me make my life
easier
yeah people you know now with employees
people always say like
what's the definition of a great
employee
someone who can reduce the stress of
those around them and it's the same
thing what's the definition
of a great salesperson someone who can
reduce the stress
of their sales people and if in looking
at your company
and looking at your your life and
looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize
that whether it works or doesn't work
you're putting yourself in a position
where you're helping somebody
not convincing somebody but and you're
reducing their stress
you're gonna you're gonna be okay it's
gonna work out and
you know that's the confidence i i've
built in myself that wasn't necessarily
always there
um but i learned that if i try to help
if i reduce people's stress good things
can happen lesson number
six turn up the volume with jamie curran
lima
the first three years of running this
business
from my living room i couldn't afford to
pay myself
and literally hundreds of rejections i
thought ed oh i'm gonna shift culture
and beauty i have this great idea and
and you know so there's there's beauty
stores like sephora and
ulta and qvc and department stores every
single one of them said no
after no after no for three years
literally
would say things like well you're not
the right fit uh
your packaging isn't isn't prestige
enough and women won't buy makeup from
women they don't aspire to look like and
it was just no after no after no
um for three years uh we got down to
under a thousand dollars and
our bank account by the way i'm sharing
this because when you google my story
and this is why i wrote this book ed
because if we don't share the real stuff
like
that's when we feel alone in our own
rejection and our own
you know uh lack of success or
attraction right and when you google my
story
all you ever see is like oh yes denny's
waitress sold her company for a billion
dollars cash and
it makes it seem like oh she just got
lucky or bruised
yeah yeah and you know it was a journey
that didn't make sense to keep going
except for every time
i would check in with my gut i was like
okay i'm supposed to do this
but everyone keeps saying no um you know
we got down to a thousand dollars in our
bank account as i mentioned and
sometimes when there's no proof around
you that your idea is right and like
your friends and family are starting to
worry about you
and they're starting to be like are you
sure you should have you know started
this
are you getting any sales yet it was
like that and it was this
three-year journey of having to figure
out how to turn down the volume
on my own self-doubt and on rejection
everywhere and kind of like tune in or
turn up the volume rather than
on that inner knowing that kept telling
me you're supposed to do this
um and that kind of was one of the
things that made all the difference
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is make the best product with sarah
bleakley the process of me cutting the
feet out of my pantyhose
while trying to get the prototype made
before i launched it was two years so
there was a year
solid of me driving in north carolina on
the weekends and
at night or taking time off from work to
go
and work on the prototype get it made i
learned so many things
that i didn't know as a consumer it had
never dawned on me
you know that men were making all of our
undergarments so i learned very quickly
that the industry had been taking an
average waistband size between a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working we're really
uncomfortable
and they were doing it to cut cost and
production so i immediately change that
in a spanx waistband
a size small gets a small medium gets a
medium and so on
makes perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord
inside the waistbands that had been
there forever well we had made so many
advancements in yarns
that they no longer needed the rubber
cord but no one had stopped to say do we
still need to put this so
i immediately took the rubber cord out
of it and another thing i learned was
the way that they were doing sizing was
just so
blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go yep that's a size
medium
and i'd lean in and i go ask her how she
feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother
my grandmother who's 90. my
sister-in-law
cassie i mean all of my friends the
girls at spanx
we're testing it on real women and we
want to test it more than two seconds to
say yep that looks like a medium we we
had people wear it for a week
wash it tell us if it rolled did it move
did it stay in place how did you
feel very concerned with spanx garments
and how they made you
feel now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week
the sign says that when you just watch a
video you get motivated you get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i think you should be doing
something you're passionate about so the
question is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford
this will go to stanford law school um
possibly
but i think a lot more about why i was
doing it was is it just uh
you know you know i was on this super
tract myself i ended up at a big law
firm in new york
in my eighth grade junior high school
yearbook one of my friends wrote and i
know you're going to get into stanford
in four years i went to stanford four
years later went to stanford law school
ended up at a big law firm in uh in new
york where on the outside everybody
wanted to get in
on the inside everybody wanted to get
out um
when i left after uh seven months and
three days um
one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz
which you know all you had to do was
really just go out the front door
but um but so much of um our identity
gets wrapped up in the competitions we
win
and um that um and when you compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition
when you compete you do get better at
what you're competing at if you take
lots of sat test prep classes
you'll get a better score on the s.a.t
um and when you compete you get
better at beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on
but um but you often it often comes at
this very high price of
of losing sight of what's uh what's
truly valuable and important and
meaningful
which is well i think passion there's
well there's sort of all sorts of other
they're all sorts of things that
that could be that but but i think um i
think it often
the the i think it often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path
because uh so i think um you know
there's there's obviously financial
version
where you get to be have a monopoly like
business there's a
the meaningful version i think is always
counter factual where
if you weren't doing this um would you
know it's great to be working on
problems where if you weren't working on
them
nobody else would do them you know if
you're working at the
fourth online pet food company the 10th
in film solar panel company
the 1000th restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it
someone else would um you know if you're
working at uh
at something where it's the only thing
of its kind in the world
that's very meaningful if if we weren't
if we and it could be
for-profit non-profit all sorts of
context if we weren't doing this this
problem would absolutely not be tackled
i think that's the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful i
have a very big
life and so people with big lives can do
big things and so i started to think
about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life
i grew up poor uh on welfare with my
mother for part of my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years old
and
my mother had said we're not going to
have christmas
because we can't afford it and my
feeling
at the time was okay well so that ruins
that santa claus bit
it's 12 that's when i realized there was
no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh i remember feeling like
it's going to be really hard on
christmas morning
to go outside everybody had you know you
go outside with your toys
what am i going to do when everybody
else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class
and say i got nothing so that's what i
was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up some three
nuns came to our house and they gave me
a doll and they bought us food
and we had our christmas that was the
best christmas of my life
because somebody remembered and i wasn't
going to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling for children who had nothing
so i decided to go to south africa
originally i wanted to do a million kids
because i thought we can do a million
kids
and then just realize with i only had uh
four weeks vacation so in four weeks i
could not reach a million kids because i
didn't want to just write a check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face
and say to that child somebody
remembered you
and so that's what i did with my life
this christmas i took
41 people from here hired another 50
people over there
and we were traveling caravan from one
village to the next we did 2 000 kids a
day
we had um parties for children
who were uh orphans and it was
singularly i will tell you i could weep
thinking about it
the singularly the best experience of
my life the singularly
best experience of my life the first day
in africa
where we had um three
280 kids in a room and every single one
of those kids had lost a parent
every single one of those children they
were aged three
to 17 in that room and my team
that you're talking about i have the
greatest team in the world my team
in the here in the united states had
been in contact with the orphanages so
that by the time we got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had um uh
this summer every black doll
manufacturer in the country had sent me
dolls because i these
girls had never seen black dolls and so
it was my mission
to do for them what the nuns had done
for me was to let the
african girl see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have
soccer balls we bought radios we bought
clothes
and the most important thing is we had
their names
on every box for every child and
i called up the children one by one and
when those children
you know received their gifts and then
waited for the next child to receive
their gifts
and said i said nobody can open their
presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three and those children
opened their presents was the single
greatest moment
of my life and i share that with you
i share that with you because that's
what i can do i can
be i have a big life so i can take 50
000 presents and do that over and over
and over again to orphanage
effort orphanage but what i felt in that
room for those from those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces of those women
when you look into the eyes of someone
and you
give them a gift whether that be a
physical gift or it'd be
a gift from your spiritual self
from your presence from the essence of
you and you see the light you see the
joy
what i felt in that room was not just
that i was remembered
that that the child felt that i was
remembered but you felt a sense of
hope a sense of validation
a sense of validation that somebody
cared about
me and i will tell you that of
all the years and shows that i have done
and every theme for every show that i've
done the single common denominator
denominator that i've found that
every human being is looking for is
validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter that they
matter
and what happened in that room that was
the greatest day of my life
i knew that those children knew in that
moment
that they mattered that they mattered
and so i encourage you
it's exciting to be able to write a
check it's
even more exciting to be able to touch
one
life to be able to do that for one
person it's like cynthia was saying when
you can do that for one
person when you can do that you will
know that your life has meaning
and i will tell you when i left that
place my my friend gail and i were there
and we're all boohoo and we're like
booming with the children
oh my god and gail was saying what is it
what is it we're so full
as gail said to me she said you know as
big as your show is
as big as your show is what happened in
that room
seemed bigger what happened in that room
sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life in a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is
not like you somebody who is like you
who
is indeed if you are feeling depressed
or you are feeling down or you're
feeling like things aren't going the way
you want them to go in your life
the way you turn that around is to reach
outside of yourself
to somebody else reach outside of
yourself to somebody else
it will change you
it will change it recently
you shared in a press conference that
one of facebook's focuses
for the next decade is that it is more
important to be understood
than be liked will you just share what
you meant by that
yeah i mean
look it's let's be real here i'm not i'm
not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've been
planning for this i'm excited about it
and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds
so i mean look when when i got started
with facebook i was 19.
and um and i there were so many parts
about building a company that i didn't
know right
i didn't i didn't know anything about
hiring or managing or building a company
and i certainly didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i mean i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
and uh you know my experience you know
kind of growing up and running the
company is
you know went out talked about what we
did say some stupid things get called
out for it and get like
kind of go into a into a shell right and
and
uh end up being really cautious about
how we
communicate so you know it kind of it
worked out okay for a while for the
company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well
i think in spite of the fact that we
were communicating quite poorly about
what we were doing but
broadly speaking for a long time the
basic approach was okay
let's try to not like do anything that's
gonna be too offensive
right and and we'll kind of explain what
we're doing in broad strokes and
talk about the mission of what we're
doing which is something that i really
believe in helping to
build community and and bring people
closer together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
um some of the principles that we
believe in that that um
that are increasingly controversial in
the world and
i just think that we for one don't have
that luxury anymore
for two uh i i think that that kind of
led for a while to a sentiment towards
the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not
kind of out there standing for things
that uh that people care about then
you know it's not possible for people to
feel that strongly about what you're
doing but
so now you know i i've just i've tried
to change our approach more recently
you know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this
speech around our principles around free
expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now
i'm sergey britt i'm uh from google
and uh prior to that i was a phd student
at stanford
larry and i first met when he came to
visit during the the phd recruitment
weekend which was
he started a couple years after i did
and
we became good friends uh when when he
actually
agreed to join and came on board and
we experimented with a variety of things
you know we had some shared interests
and uh larry had this crazy idea that he
was going to download all the links
on the web and then do something with
them it wasn't
entirely clear what we did find that
there were
great applications and one of them was
search
which eventually became google
co-founders are super important for
uh building a company and you guys are
doing great for 15 years
um have you sort of like fundamentally
disagreed on something at all
over over the last 15 years and how did
you how do you resolve
uh where do i start
no you know i think if you
get to know somebody over a long period
of time we're working together for so
long and we
you know are committed to doing that you
don't like get
agitated about one little thing or the
other i know we
work it through and also generally we've
gotten
to think uh remarkably alike
which scares some people around us i
guess yeah and the other thing i mean we
know enough
i guess that when we're disagreeing i
mean you make a lot of calls that aren't
obvious so i mean if you're disagreeing
it's probably that it's not obvious what
to do
there is an advantage to being what i
like to call now hardcore
hardcore i don't know quite how to
describe it it's a combination of
tenacious and dedicated and passionate
and committed
something like that hardcore i learned
about being hardcore
from math concentrators at harvard
i'm not going to ask whether we have any
math concentrators here
but i would say that's where i got kind
of my lesson i mean people could just go
crazy focused and it wasn't just that
people were genius
but working and working and working and
working
you know i'd sit in my room working on a
problem set after three hours i'm a
little add i just couldn't take it
the most hardcore people could just
power through anything
and the advantage of being that
tenacious and dedicated and committed
i claim it helped us at microsoft it's
fundamental at microsoft
but i learned it here at harvard we came
up with the software called next step
which lets you build apps five to ten
times faster than anything anyone's ever
seen
and after you build them they're
deployable and usable by mere mortals
because it's really easy to use this
computer
and you can interoperate your custom
maps seamlessly with a bunch of
off-the-shelf productivity apps
so we go to these companies that use
suns and take
two years to write their apps or
thinking about using sends and they can
write their apps in about 90 days on the
next
now if you're on wall street and you can
write you can
create a new product in 90 days versus
your competitor in two years that's
eight new products you can field for
their every one
and you can start to see the competitive
advantage that can be created this way
now we had no idea that we were any good
at this when we started next
a lot of times you don't know what your
competitive advantage
is when you launch a new product
when we did the macintosh we never
anticipated desktop publishing when we
created the mac
sounds funny because that turned out to
be the max compelling advantage
right the thing that it did not one and
a half or two times better than
everything else but you know four or
five times better than anything else
where you had to have one
we never anticipated it we anticipated
bitmap displays and laser printers but
we never thought about page maker that
whole industry really coming down to the
desktop
maybe we weren't smart enough but we
were smart enough to see it start to
happen
nine to 12 months later and
we changed our entire marketing and
business strategy
to focus on desktop publishing and it
became the trojan horse that eventually
got the mac into corporate america where
it could show its owners all the other
wonderful things you could do
likewise when we created nextstep this
revolutionary object-oriented software
that we have our target customer coming
from the pc world
where shrink-wrapped apps were king was
lotus and adobe and wordperfect and all
the shrink-wrap apps developers
and the purpose was to let them create
their apps five to ten times faster
these shrink wrapped apps and it worked
we have a ton of shrink wrapped apps now
on best of breed in almost every
category
but it wasn't until early in 91
early last year a little over a year ago
that some really big companies came to
us and said
you don't understand what you've got the
same software that
allows lotus to create their apps five
to ten times faster
is letting us build our in-house mission
critical apps five to ten times faster
and this is the biggest problem we've
had
this is a huge problem for every big
company and almost all medium-sized
companies
and you have the solution in your hands
and you dummies don't even know it
and it took them about three months
before we finally heard it
and in last summer we changed our whole
sales and marketing strategy around
to focus on that it's taken off like a
rocket and
we grew about 4x last year and probably
grow
about 2x this year and our customer list
is
is now very very strong and growing like
crazy we just got back from spending a
few days in dc and in new york
and we're talking to customers we only
dreamed of talking to a year ago
recently i reorganized a bit to focus on
product areas
and uh i think you know in any company
as it grows you know if the company's
not static which
shouldn't be you know as it grows and it
changes
uh you know you need to reorganize it
and just question is you know are you
keeping ahead of that
and uh looking at the
our business is pretty complicated we
have all these different products
we have advertising we have search we
have chrome we have android
we have youtube and so on and
those things are actually relatively
different have different
different things going on so i think you
know i kind of move that up a level in
the company and made sure that we were
super focused in each of those areas
on what our user experience was and i
think that's
that's helped but just generally as you
switch to company as we got more offices
you know as we got time zone differences
we had to change how we did our meetings
uh change how we do our employee
communications and so on
so i just think you know and our
technology business is growing rapidly
just need to make sure you're changing
everything you know you're being
responsive to that change and changing
everything you know every year
or else you're just not keeping up with
it during my california springs and
summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley had learned a program
in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer
program programming gave me the same
kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making real progress
on my journey of self-discovery i had
found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i love and
one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest idea
she had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out and then she divorced
me
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i should be
their dreams and my dreams were
different
i would never confuse the two of them
again you have to figure out how to
quickly easily and cheaply get your idea
out of your head and collide it with
reality in some place
it is the single biggest flaw that i see
every entrepreneur of every age commit
is they leave the idea in their head and
and i understand why it is safe there
and it's warm and it's nourished in your
head
and in your head where it's not subject
to outside forces
it can become so successful and you can
imagine it getting bigger and bigger and
bigger
but i hate to break it to you you're
wrong you're you're
there's something you're missing and it
happens to all of us and it's that
fear that keeps us from starting
and if i have to point to the one thing
that i've gotten really good at over the
years
is getting over that fear of taking an
idea which i
know is flawed and putting it out
because
then i get told why it's flawed
and more importantly they point out
exactly what the flaws are
so i can reformulate it and try it again
and the trick is not having the idea
the trick is how quickly and how cheaply
and how easily and how
cleverly you can figure out a way to
take an idea
and test it and you can rapidly
prototype it and test it
correct and you don't even need to do it
for real people get hung up on this
this whole minimal viable product thing
is ridiculous who said it has to be
viable
it just needs to be something that
stimulates
what the problem is you're really trying
to solve up till 2002
all we focused on was survival and then
once we got public
and and were profitable we started
thinking wow this thing might last
and the the cruelest irony would be to
not want to work there
um you know to let it become a place we
didn't want to be and so we tried to
think through what do we really care
about and realize what we really care
about is working with incredible people
on hard problems
and that that was the essence so we
should organize everything around
supporting that
of working with you know just incredibly
talented people and so that led us to
freedom and responsibility because
incredible people don't want to be
micromanaged
and the idea is that we manage through
setting context
and letting people run and you've got to
have the right people you've got to
reinforce that with values
setting context about what the company
is trying to achieve
but the idea is to build a system where
amazing amounts of
service improvement happen in the
marketing and the content
and the technology and the user
interface without direct intervention of
meat
and so some companies operate by you
know the product genius at the top and
we all know
these companies and this whole motif of
you know to be a great ceo you've got to
be the great product person who really
you know and it's intoxicating and fun
but you're building incredible amounts
of dependence on yourself
and eventually you know how well i know
how turkish consumers consume netflix
it's not that well
and so you're much stronger obviously
building a distributed
set of great thinkers people know that
but in the past what they've done
is try to make everything a process they
said okay i don't want it to be a genius
so we're going to
organize a process for everything and
these once in a while you heard we're
going to dummy proof it it's going to be
such a good process that anybody this
was the ibm thing
and then if you dummy proof the process
you only get dummies to work there
you know to do the process and so that's
why
we're so you know opposed to that
instead so focused on giving people
great freedom realizing there'll be
mistakes
but there'll be a lot of positive
achievement too can you give some
examples of that i mean
you know you talk about it generically
it sounds great but what are some
specific examples i
i take pride in making as few decisions
as possible
as opposed to as many as possible and so
when something significant changes in
the content or
the house of cards purchase you know ted
explained it it was a huge purchase at
that time
it was a half an hour conversation you
know we went back and forth i said are
you really sure it's a great bet yes
let's do it
you know it wasn't like me reading the
script and me meeting with kevin spacey
and you know or equivalent samples on
the marketing
more equivalent examples on the product
and the evolution there
so it's creating a sense of
i want to make a difference and i can
make a difference and if that's what the
leader
gets excited about is that other people
are making a difference and you've got
the right people
you got to be super demanding so the you
know one part is freedom and
responsibility
the other part is a high performance
culture where we say adequate
performance gets a generous severance
package
and so you know we look at it we say we
want to be like a major league baseball
team
and you know you've only got so many
positions on the field and if everyone
is not incredible at what they do
then you're not going to win so you turn
over a lot of people and so we turn over
a lot of people we feel like
you know we give people a fair shot and
you know we we hire pretty openly and
they know what they're getting into
but we're looking for people who for
whom freedom and responsibility works
next time you're in a meeting and you're
trying to express something to somebody
and they under the desk have their phone
going back do you hate that
yes and i've said sometimes stop it if
you want me in the meeting i'm
sorry i just what am i wasting my time
here for
but i think evan's analogy to meal is
fine if you could
take a pill instead of having to eat a
meal and get all the nourishment you
needed
life would be very different and i'm not
sure it's better a meal is not about
food
mostly it is about communications and
spending time together and feeling each
other out
and if it's a business or a personal
thing and
so technology's great i'm not opposed to
it at all
i just think you have to use it
appropriately and i think evan said it
very well
you shouldn't blame the technology what
we should do is blame each other
if in the middle of the conversation
you're tweeting
there's something wrong if you know i'm
not saying anything interesting
and how could that be you know when
people ask me about success
i've just started thinking about it over
the last couple years because i've seen
a lot of it
you have to have an ability to handle
pressure
because you no matter how successful you
are i have many many
friends and enemies a lot of enemies too
i don't care but they're smart
i have a lot of enemies and i've watched
people
and i've seen it and people
that can handle pressure
can be entrepreneurs can be successful
now i have some friends that are really
really smart but they can't handle
pressure
in which case they should work for
somebody do great and have a good life
there's nothing wrong with it
because i almost think that's an
instinctive thing the ability to handle
pressure now one of the things
i tell people about pressure is you know
what they said how do you handle
pressure who's had more pressure than me
oh
yeah yeah have i had pressure over the
years
and you know i mean i get criticized in
my hair but it's not so bad and it's
real it's mine
you know it is my real hair
i mean i get killed i had an article
recently that was so good
it was such a great article and then had
one line
but he wears the worst hair piece i've
ever seen i couldn't show the article to
anybody and it's not even true
but you have to have the ability to
handle pressure
and if you can't handle pressure you
have to know that
about yourself you have to know that
about yourself
so handle pressure
if you can't that's okay but one of the
things i tell people about handling
pressure is
remember because they asked me the
question how do you handle the stress
and you know somebody actually said
donald you're so handsome
do you believe this i love this person
you're so handsome how have you stayed
so handsome
under all this pressure and i actually
thought of it to myself
you have to remember it doesn't matter
god matters
your family matters it doesn't matter
and if you say it
i have some people they say i've got to
be successful i've got to be
they'll never be successful it's too
crazy they
they can't think straight does that make
sense does that make sense to you that
was going crazy
standing up about your success right so
you've got to handle the hook now he's a
little bit more low-key that's very good
i like that
we've calmed him down so you've got to
be able
you've got to be able to sort of say to
yourself
nothing matters that much other than the
real
big deals with family with your faith
etc what advice would you give someone
who's wondering
like how do i find my passion and how do
i pull on these threads and
where are they going to lead to help us
understand how you got started and how
they should think about it
well i think i mean most um most people
listening to this show know know what
their passion is and um
and they may it could be a hobby it
could be um
you know they could love reading they
could love playing tennis they could
they'll have passions um and if you have
a passion
uh it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life
in involved in that passion um
and quite often you can turn your
passion uh
into a business you can see um
that maybe there's some aspect of your
passion
that people are not doing that well and
um
and you know you can say screw it you
know i
i could i could i could do it better um
and i think all you know if
you spend your life with your eyes open
looking for
um looking for things that frustrate you
looking for a gap
gaps in the market um that's all the
business is
is it it's fulfilling that you know
filling in a gap and
doing it better than it's been done by
anybody else um
and uh and
um and you know it it people who don't
have closed minds will most likely
find find that or find those
opportunities
now i suspect there will be a hundred
people who will have come up with that
idea before you
um but those hundred people
um you know won't have had the courage
just to go and do something about it so
um you know so those few people who just
say right
you know i'm going to give it a go um
that and
often end up um you know being being
successful
how did you get through like tactically
to a sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that
what a question asked me the average
encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days i was at it for three
and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview
they told you all you could possibly
make of commission only
and we were in training for three days
it was a presentation that was scripted
we'd have to memorize the whole thing
well when you got in the field you
remember parts of it
you knock on doors you're not quite sure
of yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it
and you see what you can say or do
that'll make it better
but when you go back the next day with
your other salespeople what you see what
you do what did i say
so let's say knock on 100 door skin into
one give 10 presentations to sell one
book
but then when you get better and better
at it through your experiences and
losses along the way
it sharpens you up where all of a sudden
i got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order
commission only but i believe that i
could do that i believe that
colleges were the best set of books
because a high school student could read
it it wasn't like a college manual you
had to read
and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn as you
go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye
because you feel uncomfortable of course
you do they're not on the same
wavelength you're under the same
frequency so what do you do how do you
overcome that
you learn these things along the way you
look them right between the eyes or
their eyebrows looks like you're looking
over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile
smile's the most wonderful thing god
gave us and you don't smile when you
first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it hi how
you doing cause when you smile
everything changes
people change today as an imbani you're
amongst one of the richest people in the
country
what does money mean to you
you know often
[Music]
i have been asked or been told that you
know
you have you're probably one of the
richest
in india and things but i think
both mukesh and myself feel that money
no wealth is an end
to itself it's how you use your wealth
that is more important and
i tell mukesh all the time that life is
not about making money or making wealth
life is actually about making memories
because that's all that you leave behind
i think this whole business current of
making memories
you know it's such a simple statement
but i think it's profound
in saying that and particularly now
after papa like the only thing that we
have of him
are his memories and they are very dear
to us
and i think that it like neeta is to
always say this that you know every
moment
is important and that's what life is all
about and i think it makes
i understand what she's saying what i
want to talk to you about today
is a note which i call daily so if you
create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily and then write the word
do colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
go on the one thing i would ask you to
do walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note check it throughout
the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so
what you put in each one of these is you
have a list of everything that you want
to do
every single day and you have a list of
things that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts
is to notice something that you never
want to do it again you never want to do
again
and you just add that to it very very
simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but
here we are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes show people my
fears
because they can relate because they're
going through similar things
number three drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
um this goes with one of my don't which
is don't
drink hard liquor or beer on weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups throughout the day i just
have to do them every day
uh six sets of 30-second planks
run for three miles meditate on this
list
stand up straight which whenever i say i
always see posture moving in the
audience
say hello to everyone i just bought a
heavy bag so i'm training with a heavy
bag so i want to spend 10 minutes with a
heavy bag every day
i want to do a video journal every
single day
and i want to get seven hours of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of them
but my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late don't
set expectations for someone and not
meet them
don't eat sugar i'm on the paleo diet so
don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy and then of course
don't drink hard liquor or beer
on the weekdays um so this list while it
sounds very very simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check
throughout the day and i check right
before i go to bed and i make sure that
i check
everything off and go through it i've
given it
to our companies i've given it to a
number of students that i've talked to
as we've
gone to schools and recruiting and
people have come back to me and said
that
this is something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something
easy to remember one of the most
fundamental things about it
that i've learned that i've taken away
from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
uh everything else that's going on all
the other noise
to allow you to focus on what's most
important so this do and don't list for
people and individuals in the company
has translated to a do and don't list
for our company for square we have a do
and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no to for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast
to continue to innovate and to really
push the boundaries
and continue and question and and reset
everything that we think about the
organization what would you tell a
founder
they should do to protect and to to hold
on to their equity what advice would you
give them
well the i can always tell when we're
dealing with a proper founder
when we start with how are they spending
their money and so whenever i go into a
startup that has
beautiful offices and really nice chairs
i cringe
because that means that they haven't
quite figured out that it's not their
money
unless it is their money in which case
they can waste it on that
when i joined google the um
i was given an office and i had a little
corner of a desk with four other
engineers
eventually i was given an 8 by 12 office
where my desk
was a door with um whatever
uh hobby horses whatever they are like
the table top was a tabletop
literally a door which i've retained to
try to remind myself
of what it takes to be successful so my
office today has that door in it
the great founders are frugal
they understand that the money needs to
be used precisely for certain areas
many of the most successful founders
begin with no salary at all
um you know i have lots of stories about
larry and sergey
but let's just say that when i started
um one of them was having trouble with
his car so i had to loan him this car
because his car broke down
in my car because he broke down i mean
that's the kind of stuff we're talking
about
and so if you're not prepared to live
that
you don't really understand what a being
a founder is like i mean
i mean for me you know i'd love to be a
founder i'd love to have a nice corner
office with a beautiful view and lots of
secretary
that's not how it works right
and the great founders always started
that way so that should give you some
data
1979 80 81
i calculated that american banks had
lent a lot more money to
emerging countries than those countries
are going to get paid back
and i anticipate that there would be a
debt crisis
and with that an economic crisis so that
was my
thinking um in august 1982
mexico defaulted on its debt and a
number of countries
followed and so because i said that
i got a lot of attention about that and
i thought that was going to be producing
a bear market in stocks and i could not
have been
more wrong august 1982 was the exact
bottom in the stock market
and i was wrong and as a result of that
um let's take my employees or
i had to let them go i lost money for
myself
i lost money for and i had to borrow
four thousand dollars for my dad
it was the most painful one of the most
painful experiences but it was one of
the best
experiences that ever happened to me in
my life because
it it changed my perspective about
decision making
it made um it made gave me the humility
that i needed
and fear of being wrong in my decisions
while i was able to maintain
my aggressiveness so it changed my whole
approach to decision making
well when i went back to china in 1995
was an
idea of the internet was very strange
china was not connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is internet nobody say
ah this thing never worked this thing
never exists
um because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet
so when i go to when i go to the china
red company registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo
hope internet company
the guy look at me say this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called the internet
why you want a registered company called
the internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but it i
in 1995 in later
august china was connected the internet
i was number seven
person connected to the in china
internet
in order to prove i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we they just try to take the picture
i
i
died from a hangzhou to shanghai
shanghai to america to connect the
internet
it took us three hours and a half to
download the first
front of the page at that time there is
no netscape called the mosaic
oh so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists
friends to stay and wait because to
prove that i'm not telling a lie
[Music]
if you want seven more lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm i'm
quite grumpy i mean obviously i think
most people that way